this is ocean one a new humanoid robot
from Stanford University we can swim it
can manipulate objects it can float
right into your nightmares I mean the
thing looks ridiculous
the human body's optimized for life on
land so why would you want to build a
humanoid robot for the ocean it's a good
question and one of the very heart of
modern robotics the idea is that by
mimicking a human the robot is that much
easier for an operator to pilot it's
essentially an extension of his or her
body
these intuitive controls use haptic
feedback so the operator can actually
feel through the robot Billee humanoid
robots makes even more sense when you're
working with environments made for
humans like these not at all terrifying
machines at the DARPA Robotics Challenge
at the moment the bots look like they're
on drugs sure but with time that'll
change still the ocean is an environment
where humans quite frankly don't belong
so scientists are starting to deploy
autonomous aquatic robots that don't
require human operation and that look
nothing like humans but the ocean one
Merman is clearly good at though is
manipulation and that's a gigantic
problem with robotics right now robots
are consistent and strong but they can't
manipulate with a damn ocean one may
look well unsettling but I for one would
be willing to shake its hand